ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวัน
นี้วันอังคารค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 26
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพตต
ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้
วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 25 เดือน
เมื่อเดือนเมษายน
ปีพตต
2565 ปีค.ศต.ค
2022 ค่ะค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
27 ค่ะเดือนเมษายน
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครู
ฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา 11:00 น
11:00 นกี่นาทียี่สิบสี่นาทีค่ะ 11 โมง
24 นาทีก็เป็นเวลากลางวันนี้นะคะเป็นตอน
กลางวันหรอครูฟ้าตอนนี้ครูฟ้าอยู่ที่บ้าน
ใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะครูหญิงครูคล้ายอยู่ที่
บ้านยังฟ้าอยู่ที่บ้านค่ะนี้ค่ะบ้านครู
ฟ้าที่บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยมี
ต้นไม้ไหมคะ
บ้านครูฟ้ามีต้นไม้ค่ะครูหญิงที่ได้ครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยมีต้นไม้กี่ต้นน่ะที่บ้านครูฟ้า
มีต้นไม้
อ่า
3  3 ต้นที่บ้านครูฟ้ามีต้นไม้ 3 ต้น
เนาะจริงที่บ้านคนไทยก็ก็มีต้นไม้มากๆ
ใช่อ่ะต้นไม้ก็ได้อันนี้เป็นต้นไม้ใหญ่
ใช่ไหมคะไม่จริงๆแล้วอ่ะอันนี้บ้านใช่ไหม
เราก็อ๋ออันนี้ต้นไม้นะคะต้นไม้เนี่ยรู้
สูงกว่าบ้านใช่ไหมเป็นต้นไม้ใหญ่เนาะที่
บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้นไม้ที่ปลูกนะคะที่ปลูก
สอนนี้มีดินเนี่ยนะคะผู้ฟ้าที่บ้านครูฟ้า
เนี่ยมีต้นมะม่วงไหม
มึง
ไม่มีหรอ
เหมือนติบ้านคนไทยเนี่ยก็จะมีต้นมะม่วง
ใช่ไหม
ไม่มีบ้านกูหญิงราคะบ้านครูหญิงดีต้น
มะม่วงไหมนี่นี่บ้านครูหญิงมีต้นมะม่วง
ถุง
มีพักมีต้นมะม่วงน่าจะมากกว่า 5 ต้นอิอิ
อิ
บ้านผู้หญิงดีต้นไม้ต้นไม้ต้นไม้ต้นไม้
มากๆไม่แต่ว่าต้นไม้เนี่ย
ต้นไม้มันก็มีหลายๆอย่างใช่ไหมที่ต้นไม้
เนี่ยมีอะ 1 อันนี้ 2  3  Max ก็ไม่รู้
ว่าแต่ละส่วนของต้นไม้และส่วนที่ 1 ส่วน
ที่สองส่วนที่สามเรียกว่าอะไรใช่ไหมหรือ
ยังว่าอะไร
เอ่อต้นไม้เนี่ยมีหลายส่วนค่ะครูหญิง
วันนี้เนี่ยเดี๋ยวครูฟ้านะเขาจะมาวาดรูป
ส่วนต่างๆของต้นไม้แล้วเราก็จะบอกนัก
เรียนว่ามันเรียกว่าอะไรใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
ได้ค่ะครูหญิงแค่สกรีนเลยไหมได้คือโทษค่ะ
ครูหญิงลืม
โอเคอ่าการสกรีนได้ค่ะแคร์สกรีนนะคะ
เดี๋ยวแป๊บนึงนะกูไปใช้นิวาส
สุวรรณต่างๆของต้นไม้นะคะนักเรียนส่วน
ต่างๆของต้นไม้หนึ่งก็จะต้องมี
ต่อแป๊บนึงนะคะโอเคค่ะวัดประมาณตรงนี้ได้
ไหมสิ่งไม่แน่ใจว่ามันจะมาเห็นเส้นผู้
หญิงเนาะเราก็ต้องอย่างนี้แล้วก็อ้ะๆโอเค
ส่วนที่ 1 ของต้นไม้ที่ครูฟ้าจำลังวาด
อยู่
เราเรียกว่าอะไรคะครูฟ้า
เราเรียกว่าลำต้น
ลำต้น
ลำต้นฮะลำต้นใช่ไหม
ตรงนี้ใช่ไหมกูฟ้าดีกว่าใส่
นาต้นสี
นี้นะคะครูฟ้าลำต้นเนี่ยสีน้ำตาลเสียงตาย
น้ำจานสีฟางไม้ใหญ่ลำต้นก็ก็ใหญ่ใหญ่นี้
เห้ยอา
โอเคอันนี้ก็คือส่วนที่ 1 นะส่วนที่หนึ่ง
ก็คือลำต้นนอนแล้วส่วนที่ 2 ของต้นไม้ที่
ครูฟ้าจะวาดเนี่ยอะไรคะ
รากค่ะ
[เพลง]
แมะ
วูอาไงเออ
ราชย์ของต้นไม้เนี่ยเวลาเราเดินเดินที่
บ้านเนี่ยเรามองเห็นรากของต้นไม้ไหมอ่ะ
ถ้าเรามองไม่เห็นนี่ก็รู้พื้นใช่ไหม
นาทำไมเรามองไม่เห็น
เพราะว่ารากเนี่ยอยู่ข้างล่าง
รากเนี่ยของต้นไม้นะคะหิวข้างล่างใช่ไหม
อันเนี้ย
คุณฟ้า
รู้ฟ้าอยู่ข้างบน
ฟ้าอยู่ข้างบน
รากนะคะอยู่ข้างล่างข้างล่างนี้ถ้าคะนำ
ข้างล่างอะไรครูฟ้า
ข้างล่างคือพื้นดิน
สายครูฟ้าจะได้ไหมฟ้าลงไปข้างล่างพื้นดิน
ได้ไหมไม่ได้อ่ะลูกค้าลงไปข้างพื้นดินไม่
ได้กูฟ้าอยู่ที่นี่อยู่ข้างบนป่าทรายพาด
อยู่ข้างล่างมีต้นไม้มีราดเยอะไหมกูฟ้า
รุ่นไม้มีรากเยอะเลยค่ะครูหญิงนะต้นไม้มี
รากอีกเยอะเลยนะรากลาดพึ่งความนาคราชราช
ต้นไม้ก็เหมือนเหมือนๆขาขาครูฟ้าใช่ไหม
หรอเวลาเดินใช่ไหมต้องได้ปูปลาไม่มีขาไม่
มีขาภูฟ้าก็ยืนไม่ได้ไงกูเขาก็จะล้ม
เหมือนรากของต้นไม้ให้หายแม้ว่าก็เลยต้อง
มีรากต้นไม้นอนส่วนที่ 2 ก็คือรากต้นไม้
นะคะค่ะแล้วต้นไม้มีอะไรอีกคะต้นไม้ก็
ต้องมีนี่ค่ะอ่ะ
หวยหุ้น
เป็นเส้นยาวๆเนี่ยหรอหายไอไหม
กู
มีเยอะๆด้วยเหมือนรากเลยนะอ่า
อันนี้เนี่ยก็คือค่ะคุณใครซอสเขาเรียก
อะไรคะคือฟ้าเขาเรียกว่ากิ่งไม้
กิ่งไม้อ่ะยิ่งล่ะกิ่งไม้หรอกิ่งไม้เป็น
อันนี้ส่วนที่ 1 ก็คือลำต้นใช่ไหมจริงไหม
ก็เป็นส่วนที่ 3 ใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้าในหากิน
มายก็คือส่วนที่สามหนึ่งสองสามหน้าลิงสุด
ชายแล้วมีส่วนอื่นๆอีกไหมคะกิ่งไม้เนี่ย
ครูฟ้าครูฟ้ามีแขนมีแขนมีมือแล้วก็จับ
กิ่งไม้จะเป็นทางสถาน
พุทธศาสตร์
เป็น cm อ่ะเราเป็นทาร์ซานวิ่งเซ็น
มีกิ่งไม้แล้วก็ต้องมีมีหาพี่อะไร
ที่มันมันอยู่ติดกับกิ่งไม้เหรอคะครูฟ้า
ใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงมันอยู่ติดกับกิ่งไม้หาคือ
ก้านใช่ไหมการก้าน
นั่นแหละกูฟ้ากิ่งไม้กับก้านเนี่ยกิ่ง
เนาะอันนี้นะ
กิ่งแล้วก็ก้านอะไรใหญ่กว่า
กิ่งไม้ใหญ่กว่าค่ะอ๋อก็งั้นก้านไม้ก็
เล็กสมัยเล็ก saigon หมายก็จะเล็กๆนะฮะ
เล็กๆเหมือนนิ้วนะ
อันเนี้ยเหมือนมีกิ่งไม้อันนี้ก็เหมือน
กันไม้เล็ก
เท้าเอาเท้าสินะที่ต้องเป็นราดใช่ถามเอา
เป็นราดเหมือนคนเนาะเหมือนคนเลยเห็นไหม
แล้วค่ะอ๋อมีมีร่ามีต้นใช่ไหมมีลำต้นมี
อะไรมากมีก้าก้านไม้มีกิ่งไม้แล้วมีอีก
ไหมส่วนอื่นของต้นไม้มีค่ะครูหญิง
ก็จะต้องมี
แห้งเรียนรู้แล้วนะดิ
สีไม่เหมือนเดิมแล้วสีเขียวอะไรครับครู
ฟ้า
ใบไม้อ่ะ
ใบไม้สีอะไรนะคะใบไม้สีเขียว
เขียวเขียวๆไหมสีเขียว
ขอเบอร์
ต้นไม้เนี่ยต้นไม้มีใบไม้เท่าไหร่คะ
งู
เนอะลูกผู้หญิงนับได้ไหมใบ 1 ใบ 2 ใบ 3
ใบ 4 ใบไม่ได้เนาะไม่ได้เยอะมากต้องมา
เยอะมะใบไม้ขอโทษอะไรไปไม้เนี่ยเยอะนาย
เอ้อเออเห็นไหมเยอะๆเยอะๆเยอะ
มีใบไม้มาหาใบไม้นะไม่ไม่ร่วงหมดหรือยัง
คะส่วนของต้นไม้
ยังไม่หมดค่ะผู้หญิงมีอะไรอีกคะอันนี้
ส่วนที่สี่แล้วนะใบไม้ฮึ 5 มั้ย 1
อันนี้ 4 จัดการมันก็คือ 4 ใบไม้ที่คือ 5
พ่อไปมีอีกหรอมีอีกอ่ะผู้หญิง
มีใบไม้แล้ว
ก็ต้องมีดอกไม้
อ๋อ
ใช่ไหมดอก
ทราย
เหมือนมั้ยเนี่ย
ได้อยู่ค่ะอีดอกไม้โอ๊ตสีก็จะไม่ใช่สี
เขียวเหมือนใบไม้ไม่ใช่สีน้ำตาลเหมือนต้น
ไม่ใช่กิ่ง
ดอกไม้ตั้งแต่ดอกอะไรใช่ไหมบ่ายๆๆ
ไม่รู้ในนี้มีหลายๆสีเนาะ
ๆเอ๊ะเป็นสีแดงก็มี
ใช้ส้อม
โอ้นี่อะสีส้มก็มีพี่ส่งดอกไม้
มีอีก
ใส่นั้นต้นไม้ต้องมีดอกไม้เนาะอีดอกไม้หา
ก็เป็น 6 ตายจอดมากหมดหรือยังคะส่วนของ
ต้นไม้
ค่ะผู้หญิงยังมีมีอะไรอีกอันนี้แล้วแต่นะ
ผลผลไม้
หรือว่าเราเรียกว่าลูกก็ได้เหรออาหารหรือ
ว่าเป็นผล
อะไร
แอปเปิ้ลไงอ๋อถ้าต้นไม้ต้นนี้คือต้น
แอปเปิ้ลให้เกินผลก็จะเป็น
แอปเปิ้ล
[เพลง]
แต่ถ้าบ้านมีคนไทยเนี่ยปลูกต้นมะม่วงต้น
ไม้ต้นนี้คือต้นมะม่วงใช่ก็จะเป็นมะม่วง
ฮือแล้วแต่
แล้วแต่สมัยว่าเราปลูกอะไรได้นี่เป็น
แอปเปิ้ลนะคะแอปเปิ้ล
แอปเปิ้ลเนี่ยเป็นผลไม้
ผลไม้นะคะผลไม้จ่ายถ้าต้นแอปเปิ้ลเนี่ย
ส่วนที่ 7 ของต้นแอปเปิ้ลก็คือ
อันนี้เนาะผลแอปเปิลฝนฝนถ้านักเรียนปลูก
ต้นไม้เป็นต้นบลูเบอร์รี่
ก็จะเป็นบลูเบอร์รี่แต่ผลก็จะเป็น
บลูเบอร์รี่
ชายหาบลูเบอร์รี่
ผลจะหมดหรือยังคะส่วนของต้นไม้ขอให้หมด
แล้วไหมหมดแล้วเนาะน่าจะมีประมาณเท่าไหร่
นะ 700 ใช่ไหมคะค่ะ
ก็จะมี
หนึ่งนะคะส่วนที่ 1 อะไรคะครูฟ้าขาส่วน
ที่ 1 เนี่ยลำต้นใช่ไหมต้นไม้ค่ะมันก็
เปลือกไง
เหลือบจะไม่ใช่เป็นส่วนที่แบบตรงนี้น่ะ
เหลือกนะจ๊ะเหลือ
เปลือกเนี่ยก็เหลือกไม้เดี๋ยวพี่ให้ดูรูป
นิดนึงนะคะแบบนี้เนาะใช่มั้ย
ไม้มันก็จะอยู่คนเดียวกับลำต้นของต้นไม้
น้องอ่ะส่วนที่หนึ่งก็คือเกลียดลำต้น
เนื้อ
หาส่วนที่หนึ่งก็คือลำต้นนะเนี่ยลำต้น
ส่วนที่ 2 อะไรคะของส่วนที่ 2 ของต้นไม้
อะไรคะ
รากไม้ค่ะส่วนที่ 3 ของต้นไม้อะไรคะ
กิ่งไม้
ก้านหักอีกหมายถูกแล้วกูฟ้าสุกิจส่วนที่ 4
ของต้นไม้อะไรคะ
ก้านหมายหักการอ่าน
การหมายเนี่ยก็ค่ะเสื้อไหมภูฟ้าเนี่ยขึ้น
ต้นไม้ทำไมหูฟ้าแล้วก็ขึ้นไปแล้วก็การ
หมายได้ก้านไม้
ชาติกิ่งไม้ส่วนที่สามเนี่ยไม่ได้ชายไม่
ได้ไม่ได้อ่าอีก 4 ส่วนที่ 4 คือมีกิ่ง
ไม้ละส่วนที่ 5 วันที่ 4 ก้านไม้
ส่วนที่ 3 อะไรนะคะถาม 3 นะสามกลิ่นไม้
ค่ะ C
ก้านไม้
ส่วนที่ 5 ของต้นไม้อะไรคะ
ห้าใบไม้ใบไม้น้องพี่มาเยอะนะคะส่วนที่ 6
ของต้นไม้อะไรคะ 6 ดอกไม้
ดอกไม้แล้วก็ส่วนที่ 7 ของต้นไม้อะไรคะผล
ผลไม้ก็ได้ผลผลน็อคอาจจะบางต้นกินได้บาง
ต้นอ่ะกินไม่ได้หรอก็มีต้นไม้ก็จะมีทั้ง
หมด 7 ส่วนแล้วก็เหมือนคนดีๆหายๆกันราดก็
เหมือนเท้าใช่ไหมคะต้นก็เหมือนขาของเรา
เนาะหรือว่าตัว
อะไรหาใช่ไหมอันนี้คือต้นไม้ค่ะต้นไม้
ส่วนทั้งหมดนะคะของต้นไม้ครูฟ้าครูสาสน์
โชคส่วนไหนของต้นไม้มากที่สุดครูฟ้าชอบนะ
ชอบ
สีฟ้าชอบผลไม้ค่ะ
ตอบช้าชอบกินใช่มั้ย
ผลไม้ผลไม้ผู้หญิงละข้างนะผู้หญิงชอบส่วน
อะส่วนไหนของต้นไม้ผู้หญิงชอบใบค่ะใบ
ไปแล้วกันเพราะผู้ว่าชอบผลและมีชอบใบนะคะ
เวลาดูใบดอกไม้สีเขียวจะ
สวยดีนะคะจ่ายอันนี้ก็คือทั้งหมดนะที่
เป็นส่วนต่างๆของต้นไม้เนาะจะมีลำต้น
ราก
กิ่งๆกี่ไม้ก้านไป
ดอกแล้วก็ขนมาหาศาสตร์นักเรียนชอบส่วนไหน
ของต้นไม้มั้งมากที่สุดก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเรา
ได้รวยนักเรียนชอบช้าหมด
ก็คอมเม้นท์หรอกนะคะถ่ายค่ะส่วนวีดีโอนี้
นะคะผู้หญิงกับผู้มาก็ไปพร้อมกับต้นไม้
ของผู้ฟ้าให้แล้วเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้าวัน
นี้ก็สวัสดี
นะคะอ่ะ